the jurgen experience wake up in the
next city play some disc golf [ __ ]
how did you get into that
uh oh we were in texas ty's really big
in texas really yeah really big in texas
we were in texas and i was looking for a
way to get outside we had just been to
on it and john had given me a kettlebell
and i said i'm gonna take this
kettlebell with me everywhere i go
that'll be my one of my weight loss
programs and so we we walked in this we
saw we read the kettlebell and we saw
disc golf i said hey we should go play
disc golf we played like i don't want to
say
like uh i wanted
probably dallas or sugarland
and we went out and played and i [ __ ]
fell in love with and i used to play in
college and we loved it in college and
and and i there was not the amount of
discs there are now
back then and all of a sudden i was like
[ __ ] so i put up one disc golf video of
us playing and the disc golf community
hit me up and they're like
they're like hey man excited you're into
our sport
one all the companies started going let
me send you some stuff and then we get
like legit discs like innova sent us
everything
and so
i sort of disc crafted all these places
and then we started going out the
discounts and then
professional disc golfers like paige
pierce she's like hey you're in
pensacola i'm here tonight why don't you
come out and play disc golf with me so i
was like cool and then we're playing
with
the greatest disc golf golfers ever and
they're giving us tips and we're all
getting a lot better like a lot better
and that and now it's our group our my
group of guys and we're all playing
we're all getting better and we have
access to the greatest disc golf courses
and the greatest disc golfers in the
world the philo is this guy that is a
genius he came to my greek show i sat
with him after the show and just talked
to this golf talk forehands
and and and it's fun as [ __ ] how many
people are playing that why isn't it
like a a big sport that it's recognized
blowing up right is it yeah it's getting
blowing up right now because i had a
friend that my friend john used to play
it back in new york in like the 2000 or
earl no it was not it was
yeah i guess it was like
the early 90s it was like 92-ish
somewhere around then
and i was like what are you doing he's
like i'm playing disc golf i was like
what the [ __ ] is that and he was
explaining it to me it's so much fun
first time i ever got drunk
14 or 15 playing disc golf with my
brothers who are much older than me
and uh
one little bottle of the mike's heart
it was a jack daniels lynchburg lemonade
it was called i remember cause i'm like
this stuff's fun yeah and uh i've played
my whole life because it was really big
in columbus ohio back then and then when
i moved to cali
that's like the mecca the oldest disc
golf course i believe in the world i
think it was invented in like pasadena
or something like that
and uh
awesome golf courses there especially
that one i remember that one being cool
it had like fallen trees that were like
leaning against each other right at the
driving tee and everything so you have
to literally like it's way down there
but you have to first whip it through
these like massive trees that are right
in front of you that literally like one
fell on to another so
you have to
bridge the gap dude
you got some beautiful courses where
they're like you got to go through this
long list of trees you know who really
you know what really [ __ ] sparked it
dead honestly
is i played a [ __ ] couple rounds and
i was posted on instagram the first
person to reach out was ben askren oh
he's a big disc he's got his own course
at his house and he's like hey man
he built like a 29
a whole course at his house and he's
like hey man i got a tournament i'd love
for you to play in it you want to come
out if you're ever in the area
tournament i'm at his house he has a
tournament at his house ben askren's
[ __ ] legit
ben askren is [ __ ] legit and so then
i started [ __ ] around you know
because i if i ever get like a celebrity
ever hits me up i always play with it on
like aaron rodgers or any of those i
play with it on instagram a lot so i
throw things like yo ben is this legal
and [ __ ] around and then
as soon as ben
started tweeted about me the disc golf
community heard about me and and
you can tell if someone's really
passionate about something or if they're
not passionate and i just people would
hit me up i'd be like i'd send people my
shots i'd give me notes
mostly
i [ __ ] my arm up doing a backhand so
i've been throwing a lot of forehands
what do you mean uh i [ __ ] your arm up
throwing the golf throwing disc off how
does that thing weigh uh 173 ounces is
what i'm throwing for my driver 173
ounces is really heavy i think it's 173
ounces it's 173 is the weight
grams grams 173 grams oh it's like jesus
you know how [ __ ] heavy that is 173
grams a one ounce fishing weight feels
like oh yeah that's not it yeah it's but
all your numbers your weights are on
your thing so like okay if you're
throwing into the wind you want to throw
a heavier disc if you're going again
with the wind you want to throw a
lighter disc
but i mean i i'm obsessed i could watch
disc golf all [ __ ] day so okay so
it's set up in trees that's kind of dope
too that they don't have to [ __ ] up the
environment right like they don't have
to
you know they don't have to cut all the
grass and remove all the trees to make a
chorus it actually kind of enhanced so
this is i think this is paige is that
paige this is uh ben's pro-am so
probably
i think that's paige pierce
it's kind of interesting like why isn't
this more popular and what made it more
popular again like what was the cause of
it like having a resurgence well it's
ridiculously popular the people that
play it play the hell out of it the
courses are packed all the time it's
just like not a mainstream what does
that mean ridiculously popular
type in [ __ ] it up type in uh type in
uh best disc golf throws like you'll see
guys throwing it 450
feet or yeah yeah feet and don't say
numbers be like joe biden
no numbers
and then i mean this dude look at jomez
so jomas is based out of austin i've hit
that guy up they they have a great disc
golf channel type in this one's like
hole-in-ones yeah oh so you throw it
like that i throw it like that
oh
yeah i can you get addicted
i i [ __ ] love this [ __ ] so there's
like millions of people playing this you
think uh is it on television is it
televised no i was gonna do a i was
gonna do it i was trying to organize a
two bears one cave disc golf tournament
and get a million dollar purse you
should i'm trying that seems like
something you guys would totally be able
to do we do it in hawaii the innova's
got a great course in hawaii oh yeah
bring about all the pros down do a pro
am the day before and then do a big
tournament these guys are monsters and
and we i mean i get access to a lot of
things now we got access to a
minor league stadium the other night and
we and we get done amarillo they hit us
up they're like hey man we own the mine
league stadium you want to come and play
disc golf and we're like in the stadium
i travel with my own goal my own [ __ ]
goals yeah i travel with it on the bus i
have maybe
250 discs on the bus what i have joe wow
dude that's cool first of all
they've all hooked me up amazingly um
mvp discs uh there's so many great discs
that uh i've been hooked up with but if
if i see a disc golf shop i'd go and
drop a [ __ ] you just all in 200 bucks
you're all in i'm just going oh i'm
looking for every wraith you can
possibly have i want every kind of i
want every plastic that you have i want
the g-star i want the the wraith is my
disc it's a great underhand disc and so
we set up a disc golf course in a minor
league stadium and i was like and we're
just going to the [ __ ] top decks
throwing from there throwing like 320
feet it's [ __ ] it was so much fun